in an increasingly globalized world
collective action becomes more important
every day
but would you believe that we can learn
in this context from
animal swarm intelligence ralph curves
is convinced we can
he is principal investigator in social
decision market making
at the center for adaptive rationality
and he
is now online with us it's nice meeting
you ralph good morning johnny
thanks for joining us um i understood
collective intelligence when it comes to
fish swarms or
ant hills but can we really translate
these concepts to
uh to human societies
well i mean of course it's fair to say
that a one-to-one comparison from an
anthill to to an animal
to human societies is of course a bit
far-fetched but animals have evolved in
their
staggering diversity of selection
pressures and have evolved extremely
rich and complicated and mechanisms to
actually solve collective problems
together
so looking at these mechanisms of
different species and of different
selection pressures
can really give us new insights on how
you can you know actually combine
information coming from from different
individuals
that then cleverly actually together
perform actions
in your event during the summit you will
talk in particular about
fishes why are fishes specifically
interesting in this field
yeah so so fish holes have really
emerged as a as one of the model systems
of collective decision making and that's
i mean in one end because of practical
reasons they're relatively easy to keep
in the lab and if you work with shallow
water you can
you know reduce their living environment
to 2d and then putting cameras on top of
that you can you can
you know relatively easily track
individuals and looking at the social
interactions
um but more more important reasons
perhaps that they have evolved the
staggering diversity of social systems
so some
some fish are mostly seen alone others
in very
big groups so that there is a whole
range of diversity of how they've
evolved you know to collect
decision-making mechanisms telling us
really something about the evolution of
these mechanisms
and how can we benefit from this what
are the social areas that can benefit
most from insights in this field
yeah so in my personal research for
example we we've been studying fish
schools and we we found
an intricate or an elegant way how they
actually you know increased
decision accuracy together we applied
these insights to medical diagnostics
seeing if we if we pull
independent decisions of doctors can we
actually you know achieve higher
diagnostic accuracy
and we confirmed this in several areas
of medical diagnostics so when we're
moving beyond that i mean i think there
are many areas where you can actually
benefit from you know
pulling decisions of of more individuals
um in being it you know in law decision
making due to political forecasts and
meta diagnostics
um especially if you combine such
collective intelligence with artificial
intelligence i think this you know this
kind of hybrid
hybrid intelligence can really be a path
forward to you know improving
decision making in many areas well thank
you so much ralph curve is looking
forward to your event and learn more
about it thank you